good afternoon everyone and welcome to
council meeting for the fifth of May
fiercely just tuning to business any
apologies I haven't received any any
conflicts of interest to be recorded
okay
and any acknowledgments I don't have any
to acknowledge no so we didn't come to
confirmation of minutes we've got
firstly 4.1 I've got someone prepared at
pages 10 to 26 and diligent sorry and
their papers is someone prepared to move
moved by Windy City led by Philip any
discussion all those in favor please say
aye and indicate by thumbs up contrary
agree that carried this millets of the
public excluded portion which we'll come
to later then we've got also item 4.3
pages 27 to 29 some have appeared to
make that move I cursed and seconded by
new ball
any discussion all those in favor aye
contrary to hear that carried a 4.4 will
come to in the public suited portion
then we have 4.5 which is contained in
pages 32 37 counselor mailings you put
your hand up before you prepared to move
these as Tran Creek record synced by
counselor counselor Joan yeah all right
I'll put that all those in favor please
say aye
contrary to clear that carried are there
any matters arising no so you don't have
any deputations or presentations today
that I'm aware of
so we come to covert 19 really
so just for eticket on it would be
helpful as we normally know to mute we
you're able to do so would be helpful
just so there's no background noise so
you're able to mute that would be great
just means that would turn there's no
background noise okay so we come to this
is going to be a standing item on every
agenda for now on for the foreseeable
future and there is covert 19 related
measures so at this point I just like to
ask mr. Parma if he has anything to
update us on and the space Thank You mr.
Myint in terms of covert as we all know
we're in level three and and we'll get
advice next Monday the 11th whether we
are transitioning to level 2 and if that
is the case as a council we're
reasonably well prepared for that
transition exactly what the ground rules
will be for level 2 are not yet certain
the government has signaled that on
Thursday there might be further advice
provided in the absence of that advice
we are doing our own planning from a
public point of view the key issues will
be around access to libraries aquatic
facilities our service centers and
possibly also the trend
what recycling activities are available
through our transfer station which will
provide advice out as soon as we have
clarity from a national perspective we
will be as best as possible looking to
seek regional and national alignment in
terms of service delivery that's
particularly important for the services
such as libraries and aquatics
facilities whatever activity is being
provided and Greater Christchurch then
that is something that we would look to
try and align ourselves to minimize
confusion and ensure that the same
service opportunities are being provided
right across the region from a staff
point of view as we transition to level
2 we anticipate a number of people
returning to the workforce to the
workplace
albeit a number will still need to be
working from home particularly if
schools have some element of voluntary
attendance that may require staff who
have dependents to continue with working
from home type options but we will need
to work through that other than that we
are operating reasonably effectively and
level-2 level-3 many of our contractors
are back on board and are functioning
well and our teams are out assessing
progress so overall we are in a
reasonable shape as we move to hopefully
level 2 next week thanks Jen for they're
happy to take any particular questions
that people may have or we might cover
that off another council for thanks Jen
any questions of Jim all right thank you
we'll move on from there so we need now
come to reports the first is an agenda
report of 7.1 which is the approval of
the submission to the draft II he can
annual clean so we got mr. meadows
oh gosh you're on top of me an ox for
their chief and the vet ground
he's just connecting to audio at the
moment so just for everyone that's pages
38 to 44 if we're good to go
hello Jeff you're on mute
you're still our mute here we are you're
off meat now okay chief so thank you for
your report just would we like to speak
to your report there did you hear me
okay now yes we can yep yes the
submission to the ekayon annual plan is
a retrospective approval and it closed
on the 25th of March and the report was
put on the table for council
consideration so this report is now for
retrospective approval of the submission
to the ekn annual plan to the feedback
via yeah better feedback and so we the
mayor and I presented the submission to
the II can't councillors I can't
remember the date was now Dan but the
mayor spoke extremely well to the
submission and was really articulate
about the main points that we discussed
as a council and I just commend this
retrospectively for your approval thanks
chief is there any questions off of
tooth counts the Reedman follow back
duty thanks chief thanks chief I have
our two questions in terms of the
consultative process has he came
complied with that I noticed the hearing
I wasn't able to watch it
it wasn't live streamed and I'm not sure
whether they've kept a copy or not
there's been no response to an inquiry
about there so I wondered whether dad
meet their obligations under the
consultative procedures and French you
could answer then yes it can have
actually not consulted under the special
consultative procedure under the Local
Government Act
they've mainly put the annual plan I
said without an ask for feedback but
they have not complied with the letter
of the law in terms of a special
consultative procedure so it's a little
bit odd in the sense that they're having
a consultation but they did not say that
it was a formal special consultative
procedure under the Local Government Act
so are they proposing to have further
consultation given that there have been
significant changes to their original
draft annual plan are they looking at
going back out for through the
consultation thank you
cassadee defied by councillor bonnet
about the high rate revenue 9.8
procedure they have reconsidered that or
they just still gonna go with it no
they've many submissions about the 9.8%
proposed rates rise and so the
councillors are saying that they can
take all that into consideration so what
we cooked and your plan for the Regional
Council looks like if we really don't
know and so I don't know if they're
going to go back and keep the other
round but certainly they were taking all
of the submissions on board in terms of
the consistency across the region and
other local governments thank you
thanks counselor Judy cancer palace
thank you very much mr. meadows this
submission obviously we discussed at
length in a briefing and realize that we
were going to have to mean some parts of
it
why would we reach respectively actually
approve a submission when what was
spoken a that the hearing was probably a
little bit different to what the
original submission was considering it
was pre covered 19 days yes sir the
differences and all that great in terms
of the submission that we put together
in at the end of March so until we can
we knew enough at that time too and it's
included in the submission that really
there should be a reconsideration of a
rates increase of that magnitude and
because one of the main points that we
made was that the rate payer is not
going to understand that diff between a
territory authority rate increase and
the Regional Council's rate increase and
that point was well made and that was in
the submission and that the mayor
actually him at that point pretty
clearly in the oral submission and do
they can take minutes of the submission
hearings and are we able to get a copy
that I don't know but I guess there's a
recording from the zoom oh no it was
actually MS teams it wasn't sue there's
a different platform but no doubt
they'll be a recording and I can follow
that up thank you thank you any further
questions
well I'll move from the chair that a in
B I don't think we need C and D some
upper peter ii secret admirer council
read
I'm just speaking Thank You mr. meadows
for your generous remarks about my
presentation I took on board the
comments that all colleagues made you
know I did I prepared some notes so I'm
prepared to circulate those because
they're pretty much followed exactly
what I presented the and that was
largely lifted straight just summary
points which have helped me prepare that
was presented to Environment Canterbury
made I guess the main points were around
the level of rates has been mentioned
but also around the public transport in
the $57 increase from the indication sue
she expressed her disappointment that
they hadn't been made clear at the time
when we went out for quite a
considerable consultation and November
around Park and Ride and that they
resented the 73 percent increase I also
asked them the consideration of the
Northern Corridor also timing in
relation to covert 19 that the
park-and-ride option be looked at and
the implementation of that up to be put
off for 12 months now I did get a fear a
number of questions on on date I have to
say but you know they went and I hit
some phone calls for me King councillors
thereafter so I I think there was
actually a degree of concern around the
accost things that they indicated to me
and I'm not sure that they're entirely
satisfied that those costings are right
I got gained the impression that I not
worth judging their process but they
probably looked to the delay of at least
12 months but it'll be for them to the
team and a night councillor Edmonds
questions were on and and very uncertain
times and things around using this
technology perhaps and sometimes don't
match but I personally found the process
of is a submitter easy to get into and
felt we had a good either counsel we had
a good hearing and I appreciated mr.
meadows being present he
provided all the base of this but also
was able to answer the more difficult
scientific questions which I there's not
my area of expertise and I did very much
appreciate his assistance and presence
with us
Kassar Edmund Thank You mr. Mia this was
a very good submission and I'd like to
thank you and mr. meadows for presenting
it on our behalf
one of the things that I was concerned
about were the percentage increases to
another submitter I'm told it was only
$1 occur per week and crease however if
you look at the percentage it was
extremely high and this district was
really penalized proportionately in
relation to Selwyn and Christ jute city
so the increases were in the order of 74
percent for public all passenger trains
for so it's a very good submission I
think in hindsight there should probably
be further consultation because the
world has changed with covert 19 the
fact that the consultation put out a
much higher figure than that previously
indicated to our residents which may
have influenced the number of
submissions and support of the proposals
so really I think they should be back to
the drawing board personally but um I
just like to congratulate you and mr.
meadows it was a very good submission
and I think we made very good points
thank you thank you cancer treatment
Casa burners yes I would endorse it as
well and I'm I'm sure that the mayor and
mr. meadows made some excellent points
that he can and certainly got our
message across and I thank you for
reviewing the submission with us in
light of the new circumstances because
that's obviously very very important and
it can are actually in exactly the same
boat as us they now have an annual plan
that isn't going to make any sense
because of the new situation and that we
are we are going to have to completely
review our in your plan and they I
expect will have to do exactly the same
and so the 20 2021 rates may be
substantially different but again that's
their process and it's up to them to do
that and we are certainly trying to do
that with our in your plan going forward
the consultation is an interesting one
because and recently just Latian the
Local Government Act was amended so that
councils did not have to do a full
consultation on annual plan budgets they
only had to do that for the long-term
plan and so therefore he can are not
legally obliged to do a follow-on
consultation and in fact they don't have
time to be able to do that before they
set their rates in June exactly the same
as we do so I am trusting that our the
counselors at ECAM will take our
submission on board and those of other
people and certainly look to reduce that
rate significantly in light of their new
situation
thanks counts about if any other any
further speakers
a counselor duty thank you I'm just hope
that he can we'll take note of the
regional leadership only proposed
increase of 3.3 million and 2021 for
their plans
consenting in compliance and I certainly
hope they've got a hard look at see it
okay thank you any further speakers just
briefly and right of reply I've just
sent a copy of the consultation sorry
their submission points so they're all
in your inbox so you can see exactly the
points I did speak on and I did indicate
in that as well in and during the
conversation that perhaps they might
want to look at in light of the changes
and light of perhaps the environment
under covert 19 in the cost structure
that they then proposed before any bus
services implemented that they might
want to look at week another
consultation round with our community so
they're well aware of that so I did make
that point in the air so in from the
calls I've here that suggests that those
points have been picked up so that's
encouraging but we'll wait to see what
there
consultation round unfolds with so with
it
put the recommendation all those in
favor please say aye
contrary at the clear there carried
great so we come to thank you mr.
meadows come to item seven point two
which is the why mercury autozone annual
report and that's being presented by
Sophie who understands an hour waiting
lounge with along with sorry it's the
reports the name is Sophie but I
understand that mr. Blake well Michael
Blackwell and also Kim Henderson will be
presenting this so hello Sophie are you
leading he leading this or as is it
being led by Michael here's a
presentation do you wish to unmute
yourself you still you're still mute
you're unmute now I am sorry um Mike's
going to leave this I believe okay
thank you hi Michael welcome to it
welcome to amazing congratulations on I
don't think we as a council I've hit a
formal meeting with you to congratulate
you on your appointment with hit some
informal meetings but congratulations on
your appointment this year so and so
I'll leave the floor open to you to
present your report Thank You mr. mayor
and councillors I'll keep it pretty
brief because you've probably read the
report and essentially it was written
and we want to go now so the world keeps
moving on feeling quickly so happy to
touch on a few bases and I apologize
I've had to default to my phone so as it
might be slightly limited
I couldn't get my iPad it's a technical
issues here and we should we stir so I
think really we just need to look at the
whole things that continent
continuum zipper put forward a locker
locker recommendations that this council
has as thoroughly backed and supported
and and I think we're very fortunate to
have the WDC on board so strongly with a
lot of these recommendations it's not
been seen in a lot of the other tas
around canterbury as you know plantains
seven the hearing processes are on hold
we are waiting to hear what a new MPs on
the fresh water is going to indicate of
direction of travel and now we've got to
me we've got to recognize and be
sensitive to the sort of post convert 19
situation that with a whether this
process gets put on hold for a period or
whether approach but whether it
continues there's a wee bit of debates
around that and I think the thing the
council from our perspective the council
needs to be mindful that a lot of the
recommendations put forward into plan
change 7 they work on a reasonably long
time frame 5 to 10 years so if we stop
this process there it's only going to
push those changes further down the
track so it is important to try and
maintain the impetus of what's happening
in this process
mr. mayor fuel cheering could you
possibly advise me has the council had a
a report from he can staff on the 42 the
section 42 a report and I might just to
fit my knowledge we get a lot of reports
can I just defer to one of our staff
either say for your gym that might be
able to provide clarity on there
so yeah yeah great
sorry understand trouble technical
difficulties i can only see yourself
dead and I can't get the everybody else
so I was having feedback before I had
the the YouTube livestream it was coming
through several times over laughing so
I'm just trying to sort that out the
question was around the section 42 a
report there wasn't memory prepared by
Jeff videos to two councillors last
month but there's been quite a lot
coming through I think for councillors
to deal with so what I've proposed is 40
can planners to come and present to the
councillors probably for the June
briefing because as the the plan changed
seven hearing has been delayed it's not
going to be in June anymore so there's
no time pressure to to have that
presentation so the briefing will be
likely next month you've got quite a
full briefing coming from the 12th of
May already basically did you have
anything else you wish to eat there
Michael there's a couple of things I'm
not sure we look cam I see you're
sitting in the wings wizard there's
anything you want to add but you're just
a couple of quick ones and then if
there's any questions from the council
as that would be good yes so that 42 a
report when that's presented you need to
pay quite close attention to there
because it's sort of there's indications
near that we need to do more sooner in
terms of looking after the health of our
waterways but but work through that
process as it happens and when you get
that information as Nicky you they're
just trying to flick through so I've
been doing quite a bit of parking and my
spare time given the fact that I'm a
retailer on pause at the moment and it
is interesting around all is that when
you're going a wee bit slower you tend
to notice the drainage ditches and in
the frontages of all the last hour
blocks that are another beautiful
district and it's interesting we've got
some quite strong indications on
just the importance that our drainage
network is can play in improving the
quality of our water systems and the
streams and rivers and we need to start
focusing on management practices for
rural drainage systems and urban which
which you are working on your urban plan
so Nikki I just want to let some stage
in the next week - whether you could
give me a yell because I know you've got
quite a strong linkage with with some of
the awoken lifestyle blocks and whether
we can work on a educational program
there that was just one small point as
an aside and then the other one which
look and this is my own personal because
I'm still looking for practical
solutions that give us fresh water
quality outcomes in a short period of
time and I really want to push hard on
the importance and the huge potential
bit lies and creating wetlands within
our rural drainage Network now if that's
something that council can put forward
as a shovel-ready project then I think
that would take an awful lot of fresh
water boxes that would tick by adversity
boxes and it would just be an amazing
project if we could get something like
that underway in a district so that's my
five cents worth I just wonder whether
CEM you would like to add anything um
hello everybody yes thanks Mike okay I'm
not not really anything to add from my
perspective really just following along
from the section 42 report and their
plan changed seven process that I guess
as far as the the agricultural
communities really still focused on that
process released so on some of the the
other projects of design committee has
pushed forward with around catchment
management planning but we are starting
to see some real interest and increased
monitoring and we've looked in our
meeting zoning committee meeting
yesterday about new technology
opportunities that might help make wood
equality by
surface water and groundwater more
visible to the community and we're
hoping we can get a lot of community
support behind that so no I think
otherwise Mike's um well thanks Mike
is there any Sophia thing you wish to
add I just like to add a big thank you
to the my macary waters own committee
members from behalf of the council staff
for the work that you have done this
past year it's been a gems give me a
thumbs up as well a few other thumbs up
yeah so just yeah big thank you for
everything you do we know that it does
take a lot of time and a lot of
community discussion and sought to to do
what you do thank you okay so I've got
indication of questions from counts the
mailings in councillor Stewart now I
will give you a little bit of left tube
the accounts the monist I know Michael
asked you a question so I'm happy for
you to answer it that and then the
interpose your question thank you very
much Michael just to get back to you I
would love to chat to you and work with
you on how we can get some of our locals
in and getting in behind some of the
great work that you guys are doing I
think that there'd be a lot of interest
and in the area and improving our local
waterways I I know for a fact that
there's a lot of interest in that and I
would love to work with you on that I
would just congratulate you on the
amazing work that you have done and
that's really thank you thanks Nikki so
just colleagues just a joy to teach that
we're in Christian say and count to
Stewart you're questioning counsel about
it and mine does relate to the annual
report and and why is there an item in
the any report on why Mac irrigation a
private company and a report on a
biodiversity study that they've done
what's the water zone committee has
never seen
so we hit and just to bring everybody
else up to speed here when we first saw
a draft of this annual report there was
a lot of information in it on projects
that really weren't focused yes that was
the question the question is why is the
why Mac irrigation project in this
annual report when the water zone
committee has never seen that report and
has nothing to do with it
oh you you made your question thank you
Michael Oher came do you wish to answer
there or Sophie Michael yeah I'll defer
to that Sandra I'll have to have a look
back Internet as you're aware we two
meetings ago we had some immediate steps
funding of which again the will Burgess
is wrote Burgesses stream project was
part of that
Michael this is 2019 Sandra Sandra could
you let Michael finish please think I'll
have a conversation about that Sandra
the report comes from from several
sources so and if it's a concern for you
I can follow it up it shouldn't be Dean
thank you it does kay more so if you
wish to add anything to that Kim let's
see if I'm you should yeah just just
quickly I think Sandra's brought up an
interesting point around our reports
that it probably does need we need to
ask the question within the zone
committee when we do in any report is it
purely the zone committee activities and
reports that have been heard by the zone
committee where are we reporting on
wider activities or reports completed by
other other parties whether they be
supported by the zone committee or not
so perhaps we need to put that as part
of
agenda going orders to one of the limits
and extensive that report okay thank you
is there any other question so you can
suss to it know you thank you for this
thank you so counts the ballot followed
by councillor Deanie yes thank you
Michael and kam and Sophie for
presenting the report we're thrilled at
the work you're doing my question is
about the that were you've got the
future challenges and opportunities
sections and you've talked about the
policy signal with the action for
healthy waterways and we're the health
and the well-being of the water comes
first before providing for human needs
such as drinking water my question to
you is is it wise to have put that in
there now when the Beck policy is still
being developed and actually hasn't that
come into into law or gone through the
processes yet I could make a start on it
or Michael it's an indication of a
direction of travel and I appreciate
your point that you are correct it's not
law as such that as you presented with
the 42 a report that has been done and
this is of more recent time there's a
couple of issues there and that I raised
that fully support everything that I put
forward there that that the primary
focus of this process going forward will
be on the health and well-being of the
waterways because if that is created and
maintained you will find your drinking
water is of equal standard eventually so
that everything is connected and that's
important to remember
Sophie yes so Kirsten the so council
about it the the concept of tomorrow -
why did come through in the NPS of fresh
water management in 2014 and
it was amended in 2017 with the priority
for the health of waterways however that
hasn't really been tested in court until
recently with the environment Southland
water and land plan was there's a
decision back into it was December last
year we are they did say that the
terminal T Y or the priority water above
all other their value of the intrinsic
value of the waterway itself was needed
to be elevated higher than and they put
in the plan so there there there is some
legal basis for and in those some case
law as well about having health healthy
waterways above drinking water and in
economic uses yeah in just a
supplementary question to that is with
the current current cover 19 pending
make obviously we've seen the
significance of agricultural production
for our economy economic recovery do you
have any comments as to how that might
impact on what's being trying to done be
done in the and the water zone committee
no so Michael says no it came to you
wish to hit me thing or Sophia Kim oh
sorry
um yes I guess from an agricultural
perspective carbon 19 and our district
has had reasonably limited effect
economically on the on the industry so a
lot of the provisions with them pc-7 and
in why my career zone committee work
going forward and buzzards to probably
still take effect I mean it really
depends on where the where pc-7 lands in
the timing of the essential fresh water
package whether there is disruptive
rather than supportive of the package
but at this stage we don't see any
immediate changes to to our work other
than potentially funding sources for
branding projects among mere steps that
sort of thing
thank you so that's you
Casa banners casa duty came and this
next generation phenom entrust what what
will they be or what are they actually
particularly interested in doing and
achieving bearing in mind of what we all
we all react true now with home at 19
and moving forward and with the
importance of our communities end up it
was okay yeah thanks for that question
the next generation of farmers trust has
evolved over the last year they began as
a troop of particularly young farmers of
twenty thirteen forty years old that
were concerned around the direction that
the zipper Womack's and committee and a
zipper were taking that has now evolved
and that become quite interlinked with
the zone committee and we keep up
regular contact they are currently
working on submissions to the plan
change seven priciest but their voice
quite strong support or some of the non
regulatory provisions and a zipper
particularly around increased monitoring
creating some Whitman projects and they
I think quite a good example of a group
of people that were quite against a lot
of the provisions that we hear talked
about in the early stages and then have
come on board to be very supportive of
what we're trying to achieve so I think
going forward they very much focused on
the regulatory side while that is the
you know that the main chunk of work
that is progressing but beyond that
we're hoping to get get them involved
around some really targeted projects
that for them hopefully betray farming
and a very positive life that's there is
if it can big motivation going forward
us to try and improve the outcomes from
farming and to show them farming can be
quite a positive had quite a positive
impact on the environment
just from that one moving forward thin
so they prepared to do that than the
nonmetal trifling or do they have to do
you think they need to go to the Rica
trip
I just think non-rem country quite often
and works well because people come on
board more than being with a
sledgehammer approach yes my completely
agree and they say that to I guess the
lot of the discussion that I've had with
them is that they view that if you know
in ten years time when this process is
repeated and the plan is reviewed that
through through better monitoring and
some really strategic projects and
improving farm management that
essentially we can beat some of these
targets we can do better than watch
farmers were expected to do yeah the
first we can make this problem disappear
that the part of the pain disappears as
well so that's that's kind of the
motivation as to try and do as much as
we can as quickly as we can that that
instead of dragging the process it out
and in taking longer than expected that
you know can we get on board earlier can
we get other farmers on board earlier
and exit problems sooner than expected
thank you and just congratulate that
needs generation farm and treasure well
thank you thank you
it's very good to basing point you've
raised council duty it was a very good
debating point you raised in the
encapsulating any other questions of
colleagues
okay so we've we move to the
recommendations that contained in the
report to someone prepared to meetings
moved by Councillor mailings seconded by
councillor Stewart do you wish to speak
care semantics not in particular except
for the fact that I would just like to
congratulate the zone committee on what
they've achieved thus far I think that
they've got a long way to go but they're
headed in the right direction and I
would just like to move to receive and
thank you Thank You counsel Manning's a
b c and d there you go Kassar Stewart
Thank You mr. Mann and I do want to say
a few words I do acknowledge some
concern which I raised through the
questions of the items in this annual
report that have been chosen to
illustrate the work of the zone
committee when we saw a draft of this
report there was quite considerable
discussion about focusing on the work of
the zone committee rather than external
private companies and others and I was
under the impression that the work of
the one with irrigation was not was not
going to be part of this annual report
for the reasons that I raised in
questioning namely the zone committee
has never been has seen the report that
has come through an application in the
2020 year for funding so that to one
side I'm quite happy to support the
reception of the report and certainly
acknowledge the work of my colleagues
around the zone committee table and for
councillors today recognition that just
how popular the zone committee meetings
are with public attendance and I I
emphasize that they would be the most
well attended as far as public gallery
goes of any of the meetings that the
council holds and that to me indicates
the level of interest commitment and
support for where these own committee is
trying to move the reversal of the
degradation of our freshwater resources
and I know that it's a very difficult
going to be a very difficult few years
ahead but the message I guess I'm saying
here in reception urging sickening the
reception of this annual report is that
people do want to see massive progress
in the reversal and improvement of our
water fresh water ways and we we would
not keep faith with our community if we
didn't recognize and even in these
difficult circumstances
don't put resource and commitment as a
council into making that happen for our
community thank you thanks councillor
Stewart any other any other speakers
I just just like to Justin can I just
acknowledge I accounts to Stewart for
her patient and enthusiasm in this area
Sandra keeps us very well briefed is to
the progress of the war design committee
and we couldn't have a better councillor
in that space to keep us in the right in
terms of making sure that we are keep
brief so Thank You councillor Stewart
for your commitment and I'd like to
acknowledge Michael Ian came for your
role in the role of the war design
committee I think you do an excellent
job in keeping us abreast of the changes
and also it's a very challenging space
particularly as questions have all died
out or out around a life of covert 19
the work of the joint committee in
prioritizing work there's a lot of
change going on in the sector around
essential freshwater as Kim mentioned
and the in peace and in the plane change
Steven which of course is the closest
that were under at the moment so it's
certainly something our council as
Kidwell abreast of we're a partner in
this unfortunately in the plane change
Steven environment and I look forward to
seeing the section 42
and a reading net in detail so thank you
for drawing mentor attention Michael any
other speakers
I hate counts the Reedman for not seven
cancer Edmund I thank you mister Mia I
just like to acknowledge David Ashby the
former chair and thank him for his work
and wish Michael Blackwell all the
beasts going forward Michael
the committee is when I quite enjoy
going along to and observing when I've
got the time and it's not going to
happen overnight but I'm sure it will
happen so think you and your team for
what they're doing things count Sir
Edmund any further speakers cancer
mailings right of reply no nobody reply
so I put the recommendation all those in
favor please say aye
contrary to clear that carry thank you
to although they're gone in do it so
it's very efficient so thank you we'll
move to our next item so there is 7.3
and we'll just wait for others to join
from the from the holding lounge it's to
be the review of oh it's just you so
peacefully that needed you went to
yourself sorry pardon me 7.3 coming so
colleagues its page 52 to 60 for the
review of the terms of reprints of the
lien and water committee Society thanks
mister Mia
so this report is from a Billy report
back in October that in the creation of
the land and what a committee we stated
we all carry a review of the membership
and roles of the of the committee by
April this is just slightly delayed due
to co19 with meeting times changing so
we've reviewed the terms of reference in
particular to the addition of the roles
of the cam River enhancement fund
subcommittee in the Cairo rehabilitation
working party that
have been and I think for a couple of
terms of counsel have been sitting but
we're disestablished
in October but not reestablished so
therefore those social roles where they
had not been a meeting and and those
projects have been proceeding have been
continuing within Council but without
official of governing committee so this
is basically bit of a tidy up hopefully
we did discuss with the Lenin would a
committee whether they agree with these
roles amalgamating under the land award
committee and there was support for that
the review of membership was also
undertaken or considered in this report
however no no changes were recommended
to the we landed at back in October with
I think it's five council members and
the mere ex officio so happy to take any
questions I'll save a point about the
terms of reference that maybe I can take
during questions raised about point
terms of reference now if you want to
say okay yeah so I realized that it
would be beneficial to add into the
terms of reference for the camera for
enhancement fund there was a condition
from the Environment Court rollin which
was described in the covering report
that states that any changes to the fund
so larger changes to allocation of the
fund should be carried out with
agreement from North Canterbury Fish and
Game and an agreement in consultation
with dock so there could be a sentence
in the terms of reference for the camera
for enhancement fund the land of water
committee you'll seek agreement from the
north country fishing game in
consultation with doctor changes to the
allocation of funding so I can so that's
in in pay so in the terms of reference
which are in the report you're proposing
an additional clause stating what you've
just stated is it right around us yes
yep so in the role of the committee it
would be to seek consultation with North
Canterbury fishing game and to seek
agreement so agreement with North
Canterbury Fish and Game in consultation
with dock as per the wording of the
Environment Court decision
okay all right sir all thank you for
that
any questions Counsell Williams followed
by counts are thinking hi this and just
that question on three point nine the
copper river channel margins which
amends for Environment Canterbury and
what's happened on some lips situations
I understand the mags and sound adequate
for negotiating that River property
sometimes hidden on it from Henry sorry
I talked about the margins that that
stop banks or the margin within the
water for it was a dredging of the
spoiled channel margins say yeah the
width of the waterway for navigating the
channel yes so there was the dredging
carried out by the council last year in
August I believe which from the boat
she'd from with a river Queen is more
down downstream a couple they're out
there is some more dredging required but
we've achieved enough for the Coast
Guard to to be able to use the exosphere
their boat out to sea any time of the
year and for the river Queen yes this is
additional dredging but that work has
has been successful so far what will
make it very councils doing what sandbar
me for
Canterbury doing just a lot now the ones
of them anything it and I can't see any
work what they are doing
on the mini business I think the
merchants might be referring to my
period margin with the Willows so the
land the strip of land between the water
and the end the stock banks they have
been doing work they with Willow removal
and planting yeah three point nine it
says channel magan's and channel 4 as
they call the west of the river so yeah
anyway it's a good question I I'm just
I'm not particularly sure what that
referred
sorry I - its yeah let me ask him barman
he came to bring what they're doing on
that situation in please yeah yes it's a
good question in pre who can beat to a
Sophie with an answer
following conversation with a keen you
say well do yeah
thanks thank you thanks counsel William
sit your question Castle Williams yeah
Casablanca you're mute Sophie you just
said before seek agreement I'm not too
sure about that weird agreement with
fishing game you know they can be a
stroppy up but what's going to happen if
you if they don't give agreement as I do
I prefer the word consultation which you
also use
are you sure putting agreement in there
is a flexible enough - yeah thanks play
he the reason I use that term is because
it's exactly what was used in the
Environment Court decision so that the
actual wording is in the report that I
submitted if you want to refer to I'm
sorry I can get the number if you yeah
so it does talk about agreement with
North contra fishing game in
consultation with dock however we had
been working with these pies already to
allocate funding so we have had
agreement with north Kennedy Fish and
Game have been very cooperative and
Scott Pearson was on that committee for
quite a while and he has been very
successful to see that agreement with
Fish and Game
okay thank you just asking a question he
had time conscious as as this report I'm
wondering if you do want to seek a
change to the terms of reference with
you we need to go away and reflect on
their reading and their hips bring it
back to our next we could lay this on
the table and bring it back to our next
meeting it's not time conscious maybe
it's better to reflect on the weeding
and then bring it back is it is it what
do you think's I think yeah that's
possible are we hoping so the lane and
what a committee will meet in June but
there's nothing that's pressing for any
changes to I mean at the moment we are
carrying on with the allocation of the
camera for enhancement fun
Esper decided already and the kind of
rehabilitation working party so there's
no nothing pressing for decision-making
with those projects don't know how
others feel but I think I'd rather
properly considered in come back with a
clause in there that reflects something
as here is our year to questionnaire
cancer ban it but I'm just indicate
though
you know perhaps test the meeting with a
procedural motion after questions cast
opponent and yes I was just actually
baking you mister me because I also
wanted to it's been a long time since we
had the last land and water committee
meeting and I just wanted to clarify
that the previous members of those
groups and quite happy with the way
we're going forward and whether there's
been any consultation with him going
forward they didn't appear to be in the
report and is it possible Sophie there
was some discussion well I wouldn't say
discussion but there was a notification
to the to the former members of those
groups that we were looking at
disestablishing and having those roles
coming under the land and water
committee yeah because they weren't
reestablished it happen quite suddenly
with the electoral term they they no
longer existed when they weren't
reestablish and so there's been no
formal consultation with him okay okay
cancer duty Thank You Sophie does that
clarify what's sedum you're not rushing
to vote on that so any see to get into
my set tricks everybody got one screen
okay
well it just says that the cam rubber
enhancement fund subcommittee has
allocated the budget fund which size and
it's favorite 2020 the balance of the
fund was 194,000 454 and if there were
significant changes to the allocation of
the stand
alignment where the proposed of bond
consultation with dot and agreement of
north camera Fish and Game would be
required as per the Environment Court
decision does that really cover it yet
that's the clothes that I was referring
to sorry I should have had a number in
front of me but that's the one that
would be very similar to word wedding
they were going to the terms of
reference I'm happy to pass it as there
because it's almost a direct quote from
the Environment Court decision yeah
any further questions so what what I'm
proposing is it lays on the table so
that they're weeding is is properly
reflected than the terms of reference so
then just comes back to our next meeting
there's no time pretty sure on it so
that omelette is the meeting on it and
this is a so it is the meeting that we
just lay this report on the table to
come back to our June meeting with
revised terms of reference I was seeking
a can't seconded by Councillor Blakey
it's a procedural motions there's no
debate I'll put that all those in favor
please say aye
no I sorry sorry it's so and those who
again say no no I don't care so can I
just have a show of a show of thumbs for
those in favor oh yeah I declare it
carried thank you thanks sophie's if you
can just bring it back to a next meeting
with those revised terms of reference
thank you thank you where you're gone
it's a very efficient system around here
so big Sophie alright we come to item
seven point four which is the submission
to the GPS so staff that are joining us
here mr. Lynn mr. meadows and also
Vanessa Thompson
Simon he's sorry people just I don't
know whether anyone else's experience
with a big slowdown and connection here
some of your words are just breaking up
okay
sorry can you hear me okay now I can
hear everyone else so I'm sorry of mine
okay
okay I'm good change I've got i'll
change while we're talking i've got two
with five bro i've got two different
connections on it so I'll change
connections and see if it makes any
difference while we're doing Sophie's so
the reports page 65 to 96 so mr. meadows
you taking the lead on us take reports
in two quite distinct parts ones on the
policy statement on land transport the
others on accessible streets and the
package of regulatory reform and Vanessa
will talk to that the after this
counselling there's going to be a
briefing by Jared Clary on the
government policy statement for Land
Transport to get a flavour of the
council's views I haven't written the
submission yet but I will write the
submission following the briefing desire
and then give opportunity for
councillors to see what we've written
and but the purpose of this report is to
get clearance from Council for the mayor
and the chief executive to sign off the
file submission so rather than debate
the cons of the GPS at the moment it
would be better to perhaps leave that to
the briefing at the conclusion of the
council meeting hello we've gone quiet
yeah thanks Geoff it looks like the me
is just needing to reconnect again it
looks like he's just back again so you
reckon the seat then you're on mute
right Maya music now I'm sorry about
they don't know what hit there so I'm
sorry I'm sure chief presented very well
a very articulate so well done do you
need to Risa mirai's or as everyone
who'd go for it well just just just that
the briefing on the government policy
statement Land Transport will be
conducted by Jared Cleary at the
conclusion of the council meeting and
from there they will write the
submission and circulate the councillors
to be signed off by mere chief executive
okay thank you
and benissa that you have anything you
wish to add hello hello Vanessa perhaps
perhaps in her absence in terms of
accessible streets which is the other
element of this proposed agenda item we
are keen to have a further workshop that
other than today probably probably in a
week or twos time which discusses the
elements of that proposal seeks and
views of community board acknowledging
that we won't get perhaps as much
engagement as we'd like on community
from community boards but we'll try and
seek as best we can to get views back
from them about that and try to put
together a submission because there are
some elements of that proposal which are
certainly of some significance and
concern to us so that would be a
separate proposal a separate submission
that will need to be circulated once
we've once we've tried to get a
consensus view on what the key themes of
our submission would be and get that
away by the 20th of May with hopefully
the mirror and I being able to sign that
submission off once of we have got your
agreement to what's proposed thank you
thanks mr. Pamuk questions I had counts
the burners and put careful about
council duty okay thank you
okay I'll come back to you
any other questions councillor duty
thank you just want to query on this one
actually quite important with the ride
safety so are you going to be including
the the ride safety chain on this I
think
I think that's a really good point I see
Simon's got his hand up which contribute
to mr. Muir and councillor the kid
through Kathy Graham he's of Eden to the
Road Safety grouping so certainly
reminding Kathy out of this discussion
to seek to do that bearing in mind we've
got about two weeks from now to get this
done unfortunately thank you I think
that's very important
thank you thanks counselor t any further
questions
cast the ballot you're prepared to move
there's a SPD water paper yes thank you
seconded by Councillor redmond any
discussion counts about it I'll just
very quickly this is almost a procedural
motion today because of time frame and
we've just got to move this forward and
discuss it in briefing and find a
consensus and I'm more than happy to
leave it in the hands of the mirror and
the chief executive to finalize the
submission once we've all had our
contribution I'm particularly pleased
that we are involving the community
boards and it's been a bit tough for
them with him not having meetings so I
think it's essential that we get their
views from a community perspective to go
into these submissions as well but
particularly into the accessible streets
so I'm very pleased to see this report
come forward these counts about cancer
Edmund he was just to speak just briefly
mr. Muir as a procedural matter it is
something I think we should submit on
and and my reading are that there are a
number of significant things basses
bicycles pedestrians receiving
precedence over motor vehicles perhaps
putting it simplistically but those are
matters we can discuss in formulating a
submission so I think it is something we
do need to comment on otherwise that
will happen
thank you thanks carried with any
further speakers okay
I should reply councillor banners right
so I put the recommendation all those in
favor please say aye
con treat the cadet carrot thank you
thank you thank you to our staff if
you're still here issue a if ain't Vinny
st. Simon thank you all right the next
item on our agenda is 7.5 which has to
do with plane change 29 Somerset
villagers pages 97 to 103
so we're joined by met bacon and also
same Keely so measure you taking the
lead and this yep so you're all so you
can you can unmute remit and thank you
for your report and we look forward to
your your commentary great Thank You mr.
Muir I'm actually gonna pass over the
same Kaylee who's just joining us on now
to present the report thanks man
same good afternoon counselors
I am habitate the report as read but
we'll just go through some key points
and we've received a private plan change
application from Somerset villages
limited to rezone the land at one for
oneself out m-104 Townsend Road from
residential 4b to residential to zone
and include a provision to enable a
retirement village in the future and
it's stress that they are not
specifically seeking a retirement
village with this plan change and only
to enable one at this time the plan
change has been put forward and built
around the existing framework of the
current district plan and is not an
application for resource consent and
doesn't contain the same amount of
detail as a resource consumer we are
asking that the committee agreed to
accept the request to notify the plan
change we do not consider that there are
any wider benefits to the community in
adopting the plan change and we do not
consider rejecting the application
as the right course as there would be
significant and would be a significant
step and would only be done if the
application was so far from reality and
is completely unjust so and accepting
the private plan change that is the most
common approach and and if accepted we
would look at notifying when koban 19
allowed us to and when all of the
administration side was completed and at
this time we haven't got to the point in
deciding whether to put a council
submission in and but if we considered
to do so it will be brought to a
committee meeting in due course I'm
happy to answer questions and if unable
to met will help me out
thank you thanks Sam any questions of
colleagues no that's the Peter be so
thank you Sam and match so we've got a
recommendation here someone prepared to
move move by Robby seconded by windy
Robby caliber I'm sorry not much to say
thanks misdemeanor it's pretty standard
report and yes nothing else dude cancer
duty salami T windy same time right no I
don't have anything else to add just
that's been well-written hopefully thank
you the only thing I just just and I'm
certainly supportive of of this report
and I just like to make sure that star
for a we are the criticisms from other
like developments and air district
particularly I hate to mention the word
because it's not I'm not being critical
of rhymin but the parking widths of
internal roads the compromises that were
achieved through that the width of roads
the internal roads the lake of parking
for staff and residents and visitors I
just really would like our planning
have to make sure that they do
adequately consider this as best as
possible because if there's anything I
get from residents that live at Ryman
its it's the criticism around those
items the essay just in your
consideration of it and even if you need
a set council submission to that degree
I and these colleagues have a differing
opinion that would be certainly some
remarks that I would like considered as
you go through this analysis with them
but I see it as a positive development
for our town it's in a good location
that's right on the PT History to
transport thinkers well currently so
it's got a lot of positives for it and
its location so I'm certainly supportive
of it but just like you to be as those
things in mind place any fear the
speaker's rise reply accounts to Brian
no rather reply so I put that all those
in favor please say aye
indicating with your thumbs those
against the clear that caring thank you
thank you to estimate and Sam thank you
all right we come now to 7.6 which is
the walking and cycling reference group
so it's looking for membership
requesting in terms of in the terms of
reference so that it's pages 104 to one
three seven so we've got Joanne joining
us all right hi Joanne
you're all connected so we're ready -
we're ready for your report so if you'd
like to make any comments seeking
nomination of two council members to the
walking and cycling reference group and
we are seeking approval of membership as
we needed by the boards and also asking
for approval of the terms of reference
now the proposed terms of reference has
representation for quite a wide variety
of stakeholders from the community and
that group will be utilized to provide
feedback on the cycling network plan
which is currently being developed
also to provide and put into the walking
and cycling action plan other than that
I'll take the report is read and happy
to answer any questions thanks Joan any
questions no questions hi Cassidy thank
you very much for this report very well
done I'm just wondering how you're going
to manage this large will be challenging
I think the key to that will be ensuring
that we see very clear agenda and
provide information to the working group
and in terms of what we're trying to
achieve before we meet so having a well
organized and structured group will be
will be key to getting good feedback and
information from the group thank you
thank you
councilor a concern I was just gonna add
a couple of names of it some looked
appropriate at the moment
well should we just yeah well there's a
perhaps if perhaps you might want to
suggest through the names you're
thinking of and and then well look to
her to see if there's any others yes
okay well certainly think councillor
Williams with his portfolio I think as
it's in his area so I thought you know
didn't talk to these people about it and
then of course councillor Stewart as
well I was thinking of with two names
that I wanted to throw in the okay so
there are two suggested names as a mover
might want to think about there are any
other individuals that would like to
express an interest and been considered
by a mover of the resolution no I'm
happy to move at the it was twin okay so
those that have been moved moved happy
with with their yep so it looks like
there's a seconder for the it with
counts the ballot so it's councillor
Williams and counts the Stuart so that's
been moved and seconded any discussion
count straight concern oh look I think
that this is some it's been a long time
coming we've talked about it often
enough and we need to get it done the
some big in here to gets and my view
into some of the ways to thinking around
this so that diverse group that you have
there is going to be a lot of fun I
think so and I mean that seriously
actually because all of those who's
thrown into that pot I'm not sure you
ever come up with a solution hopefully
we'll come up with some form of
consensus but I'm not sure you'll ever
get a solution but but the air walk
wasn't and in cycleways and all of those
things need to be tidied up and we need
some policy and in and ways of moving
forward we need to be putting down
because there is that many ideas out
there I mean good for instances if you
look outside our district of Manchester
Street and and Colombo Street all I ever
hear about that as the diabolical miss
that people can't that don't that use it
say that it is and that comes from
mainly cyclists and and walkers so
that's one point of view that I seem to
get from those particular streets yet
from the outside looking in if you were
looking at sustainable streets you'd say
well that's the ideal let's go away and
do this but when you practically do it
on the ground that's a different manner
so actually having this group of people
who are on the ground the next the
earlier community I think is absolutely
vital and important so I look forward to
seeing what comes back on it can I can
st. council about it yes I just like to
support councilor it concerns
nominations I'm pleased to see there's
one city and one rural councillor
because often the rural areas seem to
get left out of these sort of strategies
and yet actual connections between towns
is just as important as connection in
the town so I think this is a really
good mix of people to bring along again
I think it's going to be challenging
especially with NZTA in the woody area
being thrown in the mix it's always
great with its challenges for walking
and cycling however there's some
movement in that area and I think we
need to keep pace with the times people
are expecting this now but we also need
to be able to get vehicles from A to B
in the rural areas so that
and we've got to find a balance between
all of those wants and requirements from
our community but encourage walking and
cycling as much as we can so good luck
and I hope the discussions be a fruit
thanks Cass about a Cassidy thank you
yes I heartily agree with this group I'm
sitting up here like I said before you
sure you're going to be after manage
them all Joanne the thing is that I just
want to like cancel fun it's just want
you to the street to recognize that they
are out of town on the west area the
people that we do you want cycling as
well you belong cyclists coming up from
Christchurch and go around but we also
also needs to be passive recycling here
as well so that's a bigot it's not just
one small you know it's a very big area
that you pet sometime will be having to
try and come thanks counts for duty any
further speakers
Cassie Stuart Thank You mr. Muir and and
I'm very keen to take part in this this
group even noticed some is incredibly
large and of this I do see that the
opportunity for the recovery of this
district after we get through the the co
bird restrictions that some of our
recovery will be in off-road rural along
waterway trails and I'll be particularly
focused on understanding how we can make
connections and tick off a number of
boxes including walking and cycling in
the greater
in a sort of a greater perspective of
making Waimakariri the place where the
population of Christchurch and also our
own will be able to enjoy a great
network of trails so look forward to it
thanks councillor Stewart any fear the
speaker's cast reckons and right of
reply here's to our mute here yeah very
quickly I think the the diverse this
will will lamb will have its moments and
I don't disagree that we need the rule
hooked up with the urban the urban
cooked up with with with with rural and
state highways hooked up with everybody
else and it's about actually getting
some some cost efficiencies in there as
well you know I mean I know councillor
Stewart is very keen on that waterway
type cover of people walking and cycling
I know that other people are very keen
on what happens in the urban towns and
how our walkways and cycle ways work I
just wonder whether the names
appropriate anymore as soon as this to
set up with the actually have a look at
it because if you read the GPS and you
talk about walking and cycling you're
not talking about that anymore you
talking about modes of transport and a
cycle walkway is not just that anymore
you have scooters you have electric
bikes and all those things and those
definitions and make sure that we this
committee actually links all of their
stuff that the terms that that are being
used and their GPS actually come down so
that we don't create another terminology
in our own district for what were
intentionally is actually what's
happening right up and down the country
thank you so I'll put I'll put the
recommendation all those in favor please
indicate with your thumbs that you're in
favor aye
those against
and to clear that carrot thank you
thanks Joey in and I think you're
staying on for our next report so you
don't have to go back into the holding
pen alright so we come now to item 7
point 7 which is the district stock
water bylaw pages 138 to 163 you've been
joined by mr. meadows where you just
handing this join I'm not sure if
joining actually but I'm happy to
present this one anyway and sorry this
is the stock movement by law so this
report is seeking approval for the
adoption of the stock movement by law
2020 and the process will be to revoke
the 2008 by law when the proposed
changes take a leap to the new bylaw the
existing bylaw expired on the 1st of
August 2008 in sorry 2018 and there is a
2-year period for review otherwise the
bylaw does let's the bylaw is reviewed
to ensure that stock movement on our
district roads is managed and as a safe
and appropriate manner and it sets out
rules which are tailored to suit our
local circumstances the only changes
made to the bylaw have been minor
wording changes which do not change the
intent of the bylaw therefore it's not
considered necessary to consult on these
changes and this process is allowed for
under the Local Government Act happy to
answer any questions thanks Joey
any questions cancer Edmond Thank You
Joey
they buy more seeds that it applies from
the 30th of April 2020 that was last
month I think is probably not intended
to be retrospective isn't nice so this
report was actually put forward to go
through to April council
so it was delayed due to the code word
lockdown so we would be looking to push
that out fright and makeup from May so
from the first of may be appropriate
well that's also retrospective sorry the
first of May we could make it from this
meeting right thank you thank you
any further questions okay someone
prepared to move was that a change so
moved by counts the Brian seconded by
Councillor Duty councillor Brian well
just very briefly we did a pretty good
job back in 2008 very good point
Cassidy that's been pretty hard on it
and just to be tweaking as excellent I'm
very pleased to having done the stock
pile or beforehand and I was very
interested to see just how well
presented this one has seen it meets all
the criteria hopefully thank you
it's council duty any further speakers
nothing to respond to the unless you
would like to counsel Brian I'll put the
recommendation all those in favor please
say aye indicating with your thumb
against is it against councillor Edmund
or any for you before is your fourth
okay so I put so they are to clear that
carried thank you thanks Joey
okay so the next is just effectively
just to an advisory note about meters
referred from committees and community
boards there's nothing to discuss the
year it's just a meter for us to note
health and safety 9.1 that's a report
from the chief executive pages one six
four two one seven eight mr. panner
Thank You mr. mee
the report is a familiar format
obviously the thing which is anything
but familiar and consistent with the
past has been covent 19 and we've just
briefly summarized the couple of points
in the report and respect of covert we
believe we're managing our health and
safety responsibilities to the public
and our staff in accordance with both
the guidance from the Ministry of Health
and other best practice advice that
we've received pleasingly to the best of
our knowledge none of our staff have
contracted Kovac 19 and have remained
well importantly have been quite
productive in their working from home
environment and that's worked quite well
having said that I'm sure a number for
word to return to level 2 and below the
balance of the report summarizes
incidents that have occurred in the past
couple of months
fortunately all of those are relatively
minor and don't need to be elaborated on
further unless there are any questions
so heavy heavy to take any questions on
my report this to me thank you thank you
mr. Peres is there any questions of mr.
Palmer
Cassidy thank you just on the factor of
3 in 2020 and regarding about a stray
dog is there nowhere on that area and we
know something when the pound is closed
or staff sounds close to put up a dog
and a kennel is there no kennels
available there that the situation of a
dog being from and wouldn't have any
other
one of many issues we don't have so the
the compound where the dog pounders as
you will no doubt be familiar is is his
restricted access appropriately so given
the proximity to other hazards
especially the surge pond when the
facility is closed there's an
opportunity for people to be able to
contact you don't control and after
hours but at the moment there is no
facility at the gate for there to be a
dog crate of any shape or description
that had been considered and that is one
of the issues that is influencing
decisions on how to manage particularly
after-hours animal management but it's
it's the the number of instances where
that has occurred haven't been such that
to my knowledge it's sort of prompted us
to need to act urgently in that respect
thank you the reason why I just asked
that question has the police not to
please have a dog Kimmie what just works
very well I just thought the same could
have been done down there not a
recession but some of you okay thank you
did you wish to respond to mr. Palmer
are you okay okay all right
Kassar Edmund
thank you mr Palmer on page 1 7 5 these
are grave and there are a high number of
unclosed cases in July and August last
year I just wondered if there was any
reason for the cluster they were one in
both months through a one case that's
that hasn't been closed and in each of
those months I'm not
not sure why why they hit I can I can
follow up on me and ascertain now I'll
do that and give you some advice back
Thank You mr. Palmer any further
questions thank you we have a
recommendation summer bid to move
moved by Councillor Redmond seconded by
Councillor Duty cow sir Edmond you're on
mute cow sir Edmond so this is a trap
for young players I've got no clue the
comments I always enjoy reading these
reports and see what's happening on the
ground so I'm very pleased to our
adoption thank you Cassidy thank you
thank you any further speakers I'll put
the recommendation all those in favor
please say aye aye indicating with the
thumbs
contry had to clear that carried great
Thank You mr. Palmer so now we come to
committee minutes for information that
contained from pages 1 7 9 3 2 2 3 it's
a recommendation there that the
information be received that there's be
received counts thickens and happy to
move seconded by I was sick enough do
you wish to speak cancer a concern no I
don't wish to speak cancer admin did you
have something you wish to say
yes mr. Mia there is something you might
like to take note of in the minutes 10.2
i think there's a typo it refers to
counselor it concern as mere a concern
so I'm assuming at least something
happened I'm unaware of it it's probably
deputy Mia would be great if you take a
lot of notice to that thank you
okay I'm sure that there can be that
note can be amended in the minutes say
with with that note and we
thank you any further quit anyone else
wish to speak I'll put that with a
notion it correction all those in favor
please say aye
contrary that's RI contrary to clearly
established Board minutes for
information pages two three one two two
seven nine there's a recommendation
there someone prepared to move moved by
Councillor duty seconded by councillor
Ward do you wish to speak councillor
Duty should I cast award
no thanks thank you any futher speakers
I can't put that all those in favor
please say aye
contrary to leave it carried great so
Joan you're um you're on mute and you
should to say you know push song listen
that's all right any report no reports
for information I come to the Mears
diary 13.1 pages to a Jo tutor eight for
someone prepared to move the reception
and who the recommendation moved by
Councillor mailings seconded by
councillor Becky yet so many things do
you wish to speak I can see you've been
a very busy man and yeah thank you for
your content your continued efforts
thank you seek the second there was
counted was it cancer - yeah sorry sorry
council Blakey I'm afraid so I so sorry
do you wish to speak on something
no any further speakers I'll put the
recommendation all those in favor please
say aye
and the caning with your thumbs contrary
to clear that carried so we come to
Council portfolio updates first one is
14.1 EB relationships just to say that
we hit a market our he-she jeweled to
hip in the week we went into lockdown so
obviously that didn't occur but Jim and
I have hit a zoom meeting with tamale
just to make sure that we would keeping
connected with the local Mariah Hariri
and what was occurring down the other a
number of points that we discussed on
the air we've got to further zoom this
coming week just to keep connected but I
know Sierra's trying to put together a
date for the next market ahi I mean even
I didn't really have any major items to
update from it they'll be there any
other points will raise those in terms
of the next marketer he'll give you a
briefing prior on it it was just simply
to keep connected with what's going on
through this time and so we're going to
through the zoom this coming Thursday I
think so
and I hope you'd answer any questions
okay so Canterbury Water Management
strictly accounts for the Stuart yes
still on mute yeah I know you're done
thank you and since we've been in
lockdown there's been two briefing
sessions with the water zone committee
just really connecting with everybody
and seeing what issues have arisen we
had a very good presentation from the
again planners that Sophie Ellen
referred to on the section 42 a report
and I thought recommended that the Kim
plan has come to W DC and speak to
counselors because it's an excellent
presentation and really gets you across
where that section 42 a report is at
present so I thought we might be able to
do it next week on the 12th but it looks
like that's full for briefing so it's
going to be June but
that's still quite timely seeing the
hearings themselves have been delayed
yesterday when we did have a catch up
there was quite a lot of discussion on
what David Parker must muster for the
environment had said over the weekend
you may have heard that the the fund for
significant infrastructure projects and
it was a bit of confusion about whether
this is a second fund to put forward
projects with a considerable
environmental focus and outcome and and
I think it is part of the original money
but still not quite sure and Sophie was
working on that in a combined effort
with ekayon
and Christchurch City to put forward a
serval regional focus for some
shovel-ready projects that have a
significant environmental outcome which
is what Minister Parker was talking
about and he was interviewed on one who
report on on Monday as well about it it
seems that the projects that have come
forward for that post Co good money
well stimulus and don't satisfy him and
as far as their environmental outcomes
and perhaps job creation so and the call
has gone out again and Sophie is working
with Christchurch City and he can to
bring together a focus by Wednesday like
tomorrow where we can perhaps go in with
some of the some of the projects that
we've got on the go here already and
particularly focusing around the zone
Committee on sedimentation or removal of
sedimentation the local River and the
camera system which is essentially the
focus of Henry Hudson report and the
camera of a fund that we've already got
still waiting on the resource consent
from a keen on that one but about year
so
maybe an opportunity and I wouldn't hold
you breathe but that we could advance
some of the the major particularly on
the sediment and quickly in creation
type of enhancement project anyway
having a go in it and the ones that the
whole zone committee agreed will worth
pursuing because we've got most of the
information well that all the
information there that you would need
which is you know the cam till here
extreme the cam and sedimentation and
removal and then archive for rubber
which we've already done all the work
for for the consent that we're we're
pursuing a well the work that were
pursuing in the basin in the middle of
town and the river so yeah that's about
it thank you any questions thanks
councillor Stewart any questions of
councillor Stewart thanks councillor
Stewart thank you
oh sorry Council Williams did you
indicate accretion you see the bitumen
from the about waiting for resourced and
see what what do you mean by the
cinnamon and the yeah now we've got the
consent well we're doing the dredging
and the basin outside outside the port
Neagle yes it's called magnate mud yeah
now what what I thought you see you're
waiting [ __ ] seen and I was going to
say it's the cam the cameras still
waiting for considering the major works
yes and I do know what mothers are being
in deducting leach okay
all right thank you any further
questions accounts uh Stuart Thank You
councillor Stewart international
relationships deputy mera concern Thank
You mr. Mia and we've had a litter from
inchi which was written to the mirror of
course and they were just expressing the
concern at cove at 19 here in the y
McIlhenny and we've received that letter
and written a letter of thanks back to
the
for there later so when we we probably
will circulate that letter as soon as
the other one I think is actually
leaving today as my understanding just
to reply to the one but apart from that
as you can probably understand there's
not a lot happening in the international
relations portfolio at the moment thanks
thanks counselor I could sense any
questions councillor Ward you might just
want to mute Joan long time no I just
like to say that I think it's a good
opportunity for us it would be a good
orbit really how can we how can we
enhance our meeting with the with the
entry people with that exporting and
just keep keep in touch with them
because China could be a very good
outlet for our products and I think our
relationship with them is still very
important so and it's not quite and it a
question but how can we further enhance
this and that there's a good opportunity
dear I think not at the moment
my viewer letters will get this letter
away and get that out of there out of
the way at the moment and there and very
much in the same space as us in G&G at
the moment just recovering all coming
back into the outdoors as opposed to
doing anything further at the present so
just for a little while we're probably
in a bit of a holding pattern and then
with a lack where we will work on that
and see what to see what we can do
thanks thank you thanks accounts rate
concern any further questions
cassadee sorry I just wondered if you'd
like to meet about the tree and German
people that we've got was robbed after
an Oxford and and nicely does it came
back to the council yes we during the
level four lockdown we had international
freedom campus within the district and
we had to located at Oxford
both German couples they were returned
to Germany and have completed their
quarantine requirements there they wrote
us a lovely letter to say thank you to
the staff to the supermarket and police
in Oxford in the Oxford community for
the great support that head and they
really look forward to the opportunity
when as soon as possible they can
recommence their trip in New Zealand and
remember very fondly for the way in
which they were cared for in our
community so that was a lovely data to
receive thank you thank you any other
questions of councillor concern Thank
You councillor ikenson regeneration car
boy council Becky you need to unmute L
still mute yeah the you are right now
sorry right government scheme sound was
covered that pretty well well we picked
up areas at the term cinema would the
settlement word when the particular
minister mentioned that because of
course that would include some
substantial the remainder of the
bridging and the lower and the lower
carboy and maybe even more than we had
planned and we and it is very shovel
ready to use that grateful to him so
Sandra said don't hold your breath but
who knows
bring Keynes has put in a question under
standing orders about the motor home
pump out station and shell Street with
the effect that the motor homes are
having to pack on the road to use it in
fact they're not but he's made a point
but it's it's under control in the the
modifications that he's seeking our in
the pipeline I've talked to Duncan about
it they had they weren't down when shale
street was done because they were to be
part of the car pack for the for the
rent at the Coast Guard which is now in
abeyance so that anyway will will will
follow that
and get it done work on the spin on the
settling ponds the contractors have come
back and today I think yesterday today
to work on taking the now bone-dry
sediment out of the out of the dredging
settlement ponds which which was part of
their contract that's about all the
action that's happening down there
there's a few minor issues
nothing big with the dog pack we've shot
the BMX track is technically shuttle
though a few were using it the skatepark
that true solo we taped it off in the
tape lasted 12 hours before it was
removed and Chris tells me he probably
won't bother putting it back again
because it'll be gone within another 12
hours and we've asked the police to try
and them and keep them keep an eye on
that but you know it is what it is and
we had a zoo meeting this morning with
Grant McLeod from green space with
nibble and myself the kuraki cat pack
the sealer sealing and realignment is
Judis that and tomorrow and one of the
locals had come up with an ultra at this
late stage would you believe him
sting it was all consulted about October
has come up with an alteration and we
went through the his his submission and
took it on board although we don't we
haven't changed anything
we don't think he we think our planners
are right and he isn't but grant wanted
they wanted the the input from us so
that's me
thank you okay Thank You counsel begging
these questions just firstly for me the
the question from board member Qian's
you see an understanding or is it under
the community board doesn't say in his
email that was that came out this
afternoon I presume he's putting it to
the community board yes okay no I just
hadn't seen it foot four here so that's
okay any other questions of counsel
Becky thanks Council Becky
so item 14.5 climate change and
sustainability cancer mailings lucky
last yes so you
during the time previous to and during
lockdown our climate change and
sustainability think tanks have been
fairly busy
Veronica spittle and the policy teams in
the process of completing an
organization-wide climate change
adaptation survey which inventories the
steps that our council is taking or
needs to consider towards climate change
adaptation PJ's also working on drafting
a climate change policy for council
which will be the overarching document
from which they'll then incorporate
strategies across a five to six
different work streams throughout
Council Trevor and the Planning
Department has indicated that the new
data on national hazards is being
incorporated into planning approach
which takes climate change into account
which includes the rapid hazard modeling
and the coastal hazards assessment
report which were just waiting on
finalization for Mike O'Connell has
reported to our community boards about
the corporate sustainability strategy
and to ANR just previous to lock down
against the goals therein he is
currently in the process of developing
stage two of the sustainability strategy
and is looking to appoints elected
members 1h from each of the community
boards is elected sustainability
champions look I've seen several several
communications regarding the effective
of kovat 19 on climate change efforts
however the most pertinent observation
that I can see is that our situation has
highlighted that how we responds either
a golden opportunity to make gains in
climate change and sustainability or we
can squander it in the name of
cost-cutting and status quo thinking I
urge this council to stay the course and
focus on green initiatives that will add
value to the climate change and
sustainability efforts and I hope our
government does the same that's really
it for me thanks Nikki any questions of
Nikki all right thank you Nikki
all right so come to item 15 which is
questions are hip none understanding
orders there are no there is no agent
general business I'm aware of
understanding orders
so within come to item 17 meters to be
considered by the public excluded now
I'll move from the cheer there is the
recommendation the public be excluded
from the following parts of the
Proceedings of this meeting in for the
reasons the outlined below so do I have
someone here to seek and seeking to buy
accounts or Becky I'll put in all those
in favor please say aye
aye contrary to clear that they're
carried to wear now in public excluded
so
you